bring it on
all right folks i have been
appropriately reprimanded for my potty
mouth in the pre-show and now it is time
for
binge battle presented by rotten
tomatoes i am mark ellis your host and
i'm thrilled
to have two competitors are gonna be
duking it out for supremacy in the world
of avatar the last airbender the hit
show
that is now streaming on netflix
originally debuted
over a decade ago and it is one of the
very rare shows that you will find all
three of its seasons are at a perfect
100 percent
on the tomato meters an incredible feat
and probably the reason why
there was a big budget movie made about
we're not going to talk about that movie
but we'll remind you all that not only
is it currently streaming on netflix you
can catch up on all three seasons you
can also
check out whenever the new live action
series it is going to be on netflix airs
probably next year at the earliest but
it's something to look forward to
in the meantime we have a great debate
scheduled i'm here to welcome
maud garrett the host of fresh daily on
quibby and she's the creator of geekbom
mod it has been too long
how are you oh it's so good to be back
on rotten tomatoes uh
i've been really good very busy
obviously hosting the show every single
week but i'm so stoked that we get to
talk about avatar and can i just say
that ever since we announced that we
were going to be debating this my dms
and discord and everything has been
firing up because so many people love
this show
and have an awful lot of opinions about
it but it's coming from their heart and
soul
so this is really exciting this is going
to be a lot of fun
and her opponent today representing the
great city of brooklyn
new york she is caramelhorn
at the blurred girl you can find her on
all social media as well as her website
the blurred girl caramel thank you so
much for joining us here today
what's new in your world thanks for
having me uh
not much is new because it's still
quarantined
uh but i will say that what some of this
time this downtime has
given me is a chance to do a couple
things one start my own live show which
i have on twitch every tuesday the blur
girl live
as well as catch up on airbender which
believe it or not
before a couple weeks ago my boyfriend
hadn't seen and when i found out the
moment it hit netflix
that's what we spent watching and i'd
seen it so many times
prior prior so when you guys called me
they're like you know
do you know anything about airbender i'm
like have you met me
um so yeah i'm just super excited to be
here
and same same as the moment i announced
this fans went crazy
people there's a reason why this show is
so loved and i think we're going to dive
into that today
yeah i'll tell you it's been really
exciting just getting prepped to host
this because this is the show that i'm
most uh unfamiliar with coming into this
matchup i've gotten to check on a number
of episodes since i knew i was going to
be hosting this but we've had a ton of
binge battles thus far in the later part
of the spring early part of the summer
none have gotten the early social media
attraction as this and we have primarily
caramel and mod to thank for that
because all their great fans are now
hanging out with us
either on youtube or on facebook and if
you are on facebook right now
not only do we love having you here you
also are going to determine the winner
of each round and the ultimate winner of
today's binge battle how do you do it
it is very simple you see that thumbs up
under mod if you think mod had the
better argument you like mods pick
better then you click that
thumbs up that's the like button if you
think caramel is bringing more heat to
the table you like her
choice better you hit that heart that's
the love button so you love karama you
like ma don't mod
we we love you equally but we're just
saying for the sake of saying
the votes mod gets the thumbs up gets
the heart is that okay with both of you
oh wait no i have to say that
[Laughter]
we have a very active chat room already
too this is great i love seeing all
these people in here who just already
throwing in their favorite things about
avatar the last airbender
we're about to get going here i don't
even think we need a practice run i'm
pretty sure you could have woken
caramel and mod up and just been like
hey five minutes you're on and we're
here
and they're ready to go so without
further ado let's get to our round
one topic and that is gonna be i mean
the show's called avatar the last
airbender so we have to talk about all
the different
bends that we can have who or what is
the best bending
in the show karama i'm gonna give you a
minute to start off what is your opening
argument
i think earth bending it's literally the
strongest form out there
toph is one of my favorite characters
and think about it
if i had earthbending i wouldn't have to
carry any weapons i could just literally
grab a hunk of the street or
a piece of tree and just throw it at
somebody um
she's also a character that's literally
grounded i know it's not about the
character but a lot of the earth bending
leads to other forms as well like metal
bending
you could do weapons you can create
shields i mean there's really not much
you cannot do
with earth and you can actually it's
because it's so strong you can sort of
overtake some of the other forms as well
i think
i think earth bending is the strongest
form
alright i feel inspired man i feel like
uh karen
is is like my summer camp counselor tell
me all the great things about nature so
how do you counter her earth bending
with what
water bending we are talking about the
best element here
and i understand that earth is strong
but at the same time earthbenders are
notoriously stubborn
and more grounded and unmovable whereas
the water bending is fluid
it is healing quite literally it
is um all about sort of like change and
support
uh the waterbenders that we've seen are
the most compassionate there
they are the ones that are totally
understanding that
they work with water they're not
manipulating it they're not creating it
they are at one with it um you can
totally change
the water whether you want to make it
hot and steam whether you want to
ice it and make frozen canals or ways to
transport
through that um but the ice knives are
my favorite and the other favorite moves
that i have with this one is when katara
uses tentacle arms with it so you can
water whip
you can throw the ice as well it's first
and foremost defensive but can also be
offensive and i kind of love that
they're not out to be aggressive with it
kind of like the fire benders
but it's all about sort of like helping
first um but yeah
karama you said what is one thing that
earth vendors can't do it's healing and
i think the fact that water can heal
makes it the superior element all right
mod
channeling her inner bruce lee with the
b water claim so
karen i'm going to go back to you for a
rebuttal you heard maud's argument she
made a pretty good case for water so how
is earth going to be better than water
and i personally think again metal
bending i'm going to lean into metal
bending here because if i could have
this power i would
be a metal bender and if i was a metal
bender i could heal
things i could remove toxins and lead
from water you'd need my help with that
i could get heavy metals out of the soil
so it could become fertile again
iron deficiency and anemia thing of the
past lead poisoning
i could treat it instantly so i think
there's a lot of healing things that can
be done
when you're looking at the various forms
of earth bending including
metal bending in fact there's a great
fan artist named marcus williams
he said a whole series of fan art about
gold bending in a whole gold bending
tribe
so listen i honestly think still it can
be strong it can be soft it
can be used defensive in war and it can
heal and don't even get me started in a
lava bending
all right it's it's it sounds like if
nothing else the the metal bending is
going to come in handy if you live in a
city like
new york or l.a and you can kind of
clean up your water supply
uh mod your rebuttal to caramels
well that's a great thing that you
mentioned about today's day and age we
are eliminating the earth we are making
sure that it is all covered and that
there's not much access to it
but at the end of the day the earth is
made up of 70
water this is not a shortage that we
will have in supply anytime
soon and the body the human body is made
up of 60
water if we do not have earth in our
lives we don't particularly die
if we do not have water humans will
perish
and i want to highlight some of the ways
that water bending was used in the
series that was super impressive
you had the swamp benders that would
manipulate the vines and make vine
creatures
um upper was able to go underwater with
his air mask his air
bubble that was um provided by katara
they got through the serpent's pass by
literally doing a moses and splitting
the waterways there
but the best thing and i'm gonna go here
is that uh waterbenders if the moon is
right
can blood bend because the water
obviously 60
of the human body is water you can
manipulate
and control people so you can physically
stop
another from bending is it ethically
responsible to do that
probably not but does it make it the
most powerful element to master
yes it does you can give life and you
can stop life
and you can take life wow this is just
really making me feel like a useless
piece of flesh here because i can't do
any of this stuff that we're talking
about
so reminder to everybody out there
watching us on facebook we need your
votes and we need them now we're about
to get to the final arguments before we
do i'll remind y'all that
if you think mod garrett is making the
better argument this round you want to
hit that thumbs up
like button if you think it is caramel
to lose
then you hit that love button to go with
the blurred girl so
karen i'm going to throw it back to you
you get uh 10 15 seconds your final
salvo
for earth bending you are absolutely
right blood bending
is a very very strong very powerful and
deadly art form and water is cute and
blood bending is
very dangerous but if i drop a train on
you you're not going anywhere
well i can top it with with ice
flamingo i mean we can help
make it rain but you know we can make it
rain we can stop
droughts um and also in this day and age
if there's another shortage of toilet
paper water bending
instant per day you know what you
might have won a lot of fans with that
last fedex
but as we get to the end of round number
one now it's up to us to tabulate the
votes so a lot of people joining us
right now both on youtube and on
facebook where you can influence the
decisions so
great arguments amanda heffington is on
here and she says water she agrees with
maude philippo says earth is definitely
the favorite but he does acknowledge
that water does have that blood bending
ability possibly
that might sway it so we have lucy in
here who's saying that uh
caramel what was amazing uh jimmy uh
nyan says blood bending is horrifying
i agree with you and anthony has the
best point of all because he says bidet
four days and that is the way it breaks
in round number one it looks like the
slight winner by the thinnest of margins
is gonna be mod water bending garrett so
mod you go up
one nothing after round number one
that's because we've all you know
had to measure out some toilet paper the
last few months
it's i think uh i think you really
appealed to our hearts and our current
mindset and state of the world there
with that last one
so mod you're gonna be kicking off round
number two as you enjoy your one nothing
lead
and round number two it's all about
character arcs so
there's so many great characters you can
glom onto and really pull for root
against
in avatar the last airbender but mod who
had the best character arc
in the three seasons this was such a
tough debate i spent a lot of time
thinking about this and i have a very
very uh big competition here because i
will agree with a lot of what camera has
to say with hers but
i'm looking at the sense of an arc with
the story's progression because of the
character and
because of that i'm going with aang i
really truly feel that aang has
had the best arc not in the sense from
you know going from a to b
but the depth of it all i mean he
started his life
knowing that everything that everyone
and everything that he had was gone
so he was completely isolated he is the
chosen one
which means that he has the weight of
the world on his shoulders but he
doesn't know anyone he's had to make
friends he's had to ask for help and
he's had to learn
what the responsibility of the avatar
entails and that is super frightening
so not only has he got to master all the
elements he has to unlock his chakras
he has to communicate with his past
lives he has to master the avatar state
which is not only his strongest uh thing
ever
but also where he's the most weakest as
well um
he falls in love he has to navigate sort
of these particular relationships
he's going not only up against other
people but other entire districts and
nations and people within leadership
positions
he loses his best friend upper um
basically all of these things that are
happening
he's wearing all of it and i think that
there's a reason why it's called
avatar the last airbender because this
is his
story and it's multifaceted okay
a convincing argument right out of the
gate for aang so
karama how do you counter mods and
character arc
i'm sorry i i gotta go with zuko and i
think most of the fans would agree he
doesn't just have the best
character arc in avatar he is one of the
best arcs in modern fiction i think in
the last
25 years why he doesn't just go from bad
guy to good guy
he screws up along the way in the
beginning we all know what zuko wanted
he was after aang's head and it was
simply because he was banished
and he wanted to bring the avatar back
to his father
regain his role as prince become get his
legacy back but by the end of book one
his resolve is wavering the fire nation
tries to kill him
more than once but then the avatar saves
his life so what's his purpose
he goes from prince to pauper because
he's his sister tricks him and he has to
get away from her
along with iro and he while he's like
couch searching trying to
count couch surfing excuse me trying to
find a place to live
he finds out what the fire nation has
actually done to the people of the earth
kingdom and a lot of the other kingdoms
and then just when you think he's
learned his lesson he betrays everyone
and goes
back to the fire nation see this isn't a
straight line he's up and down and he's
bringing us all with him
and he's touching every single one of
the other characters
this is the interesting thing ever once
he gets everything
that he could possibly want home father
acceptance girlfriend three meals a day
he still doesn't have enough and it's
because
he is embattled he's embattled with
himself
he it's not until he finds out that his
paternal great-grandfather fire lord
zozin
who started the 100-year war basically
killed his maternal great-grandfather
avatar roku
at the top of volcano that he realizes
that the war inside of him
is literally not just his head but in
his bloodline
he finds the strength to confront his
father his abuser the man who burned his
face
and he leaves and has to relearn
everything it's he has to relearn how to
communicate
he has to relearn bending he he knows
everybody hates him
but he accepts that and he he works to
regain
everyone's trust because he knows his
purpose
is to give fire to teach fire to aang
so that he can then bring balance back
to the world he cannot do it without the
missing piece
zuko is that missing piece he
and couldn't have done anything without
zuko so i still hold it at zuko
all right so aang's character arc may be
influenced by zuko's and
when you say zuko's character arc it's
it's i wasn't great at trigonometry but
it's more like that sine cosine wave
you're up
you're down you're all over the place so
we have some fans already chiming in
this is getting very heated in the
facebook chat
uh lauren nicole says zuko is life
growth
goals uh ali stoneham says loves aang
but loves zuko more so it's a whole lot
of love right now
if you think that karama has a better
argument go ahead and click that love
button click the heart if you think mod
is bringing more to the table then click
that like thumbs up button so mod
the 30 second rebuttal you can kick it
off
we are talking about the best arcs and i
love zuko's arc but i've seen it before
this is a very stereotypical trope that
we have seen
um i mean kylo ren i watch star wars it
is a copy paste
uh previously it kind of reminds me of
snape in the harry potter series
and this whole thing is for the majority
of the story
they're the bad guy and it is
predictable that they will come save the
day at the last minute but we cannot
ignore that for five
sixths of this story he has done
incredibly awful and painful things
you can't just wipe away the majority of
the bad decisions that he's made
i do i understand and like that there
was growth there but ang's story is
going from good
to absolute greatness and i think that
that is important you mentioned that
zuko is a piece of the puzzle
he is one piece the big picture is
aang and when we come down to the fact
that zuko's main drive
was the fact that his number one um
trigger for everything was his father
the reason why he is is the fight that
he's having against his father
who actually fights his father ang
at the end of the day it comes down to
aang
and his um zuko's father uh so
they i think aang is actually fulfilling
zuko's prophecy
anyway
mark i'll wait for you to say what
happens
sweet all right we're back and
we have the combination sorry about that
we had to uh had to take molly out real
quick for a
little sidebar and sorry to interrupt
what was
mounting to be an impressive counter
argument to mods rebuttal so
if you're joining us a little late or if
you're restarting there we have
mod and karama currently mod is up one
nothing because she won round number one
which was the best ben
mod wanted out with the water argument
but now it's
aang vs zuko it would it be anybody else
here's the character arc argument and to
summarize
two great opening salvos from mod first
and then caramel
mod had a delightful rebuttal that we
got to see in full and then karama got
cut off a little bit so camera
i'm gonna spot you another 30 seconds
hit us with some of that
zuko know how okay what i was saying was
i disagree with matt's point about him
being a stereotypical character
i actually think he has got it he looks
like he starts that way
but at the end his growth is so
different
zuko's greatest achievement is actually
learning how to be an ally
when he leaves the fire nation he
realizes that
he might have the next time he sees his
family he might have to kill them first
okay that's huge second every member of
the team
has lost something because of the fire
nation you're absolutely right mod
they've done some terrible things and
i'm going to use katara as an example
for for why i think zuko deserves like
all the praise
katara said i will never trust you
because the fire nation killed my mom
zuko didn't turn around and say not all
fire nation
he didn't turn around and say what does
that have to do with me
that was my ancestors thousands of years
ago
i didn't hurt you stop blaming me for
what my ancestors did
he said no i'm sorry you're right the
fire nation did some
terrible things my family has done some
unspeakable things i can't change that
all i can do is show you how i'm here to
make a difference
he teaches aang air bending goes with
him to teach
to learn even more he finds saka and
katara's father
then in an act of complete selflessness
he finds
the fire nation soldier that killed
katara's
mother and tells her look do whatever
you got to do i'll back your play
that is how you prove that you're an
ally that is the greatest
greatest greatest achievement that i
think
zuko has done not just because he's gone
from bad to good
but because he recognizes that the
people that he came from
are not great they're terrible and
they've done some terrible things
but he's going to be the change i'm
sorry it's still for me zuko's hand down
all right so we're going to tabulate the
votes here and get just a quick
final argument from each competitor it's
neck and neck right now tell you guys
that much so again you're voting for
caramel with your heart you're voting
for mod with the thumbs up so mod
uh final 10 second argument for your boy
ang
oh yeah i never broke up with his
girlfriend over text
not ever acceptable
i would i would actually agree with that
i don't think i've ever have i ever
molly if i i don't think
molly says i've never done that so good
i'm clear of that and karema final word
goes to you
yes the title of the show is the last
airbender yes and we all know that aang
sort of has that title but when you
think about it when the air
benders went away the previous avatar
was a fire lord
this is his family line he comes from
fire lord avatar roku
all right so the you all really
not only have seen this show y'all have
digested it this is really good stuff
we're getting deep in here
and the chat thank you guys so much for
coming back to facebook
we had a little time out there and
you're back and
everybody's celebrating it it just it
warms my heart so john
chimes in and says aang was also a
terrible father which zuko
was not um so keith cooper says roku was
the man
so we have a lot of different opinions
here coming in
and when it all comes down to it it does
appear that the
hearts won out and karama has tied the
score
one to one she's on the scoreboard after
winning round number two the character
arc so
it's one to one and this is kind of the
match-up we would have expected as we
move into round three somebody's gonna
have the lead once again after this
round again you're voting for caramel
with the heart you're voting for mod
with the like
and our topic today this is maybe the
one i was most looking forward to
because
what's a great moment or quote from
ero carama starting with you
okay so first it's iro i love you but
when you watch the show
i'm glad you're here so
the best ira moment in my opinion is
season two um episode 14
in tales of ira when he sits at his
son's grave
and sings the little soldier boy song um
because aryl lost his son
lieutenant so he's sitting at the grave
singing this song and every time i hear
it i'd
burst into tears but the the episode
actually starts with him singing the
song
to another little boy who was crying in
a market and then you realize the whole
reason why he's in boston
say at this at this time the whole
reason why he's sitting at this tree
is so he can make that annual visit to
his son's grave
and when you get that and you understand
the whole story behind that it's such a
huge huge powerful moment
so for me it's it's uncle iro singing
little soulja boy
all right well i don't know if it's
going to be my favorite ira moment but
certainly
the chat helping me out and backing
karma up with the pronunciation of the
name
they're sounding it out phonetically
with emojis there's an eye and then
there's somebody in a boat rowing so
thank you to everybody out there
for educating me the matriculation of
mark ellis and higher learning
continues mod time for some more
education with your choice
well you gave us the best eye roll
moment so thank you for that
my favorite iro moment or we'll just
affectionately call him uncle
uh comes from book to episode nine
uh the bitter work episode where iro
his beautiful quote is it is important
to draw wisdom from many different
places
uh this is when uh obviously zuko has
been banished and all of book two he's
traveling with his uncle and he's kind
of like learning to re
uh adjust to life and to figure out what
his purpose is and he's haunted by
his banishment um and i i love this
moment because as
karama did an amazing job expressing
zuko has an incredible arc
he really does um and in this particular
case he's so focused on his past
and with fire bending and the fire
nation
and he's so caught up in that that it's
almost burning him alive
um and what iro is trying to educate him
about
is you just know one little pocket of
all of the world
and now that you are out of your
beautiful glass castle
you get to experience life and you get
to experience other people like it's not
only in a class
system where he was a prince and now
he's like a porpo as you were saying
but also through different elements and
i think that this is such a timely
message especially now
when iro is inviting zuko in his
privileged
little boxed off life to look at his
privilege
and to open himself up to other
perspectives and only with that
if he sees other people like through
their lens and if he walks a mile in
other people's shoes
only then will he understand the big
picture here and have
growth and really come to uh
be who he is at the end like i think as
soon as that
key crucial moment happened that is when
his path to growth
actually continued like happens we're
talking about
doing these ones that was what set him
off into the trajectory of being better
yeah it sounds like you all might have
be on different sides of the fence here
but i think we can all agree we could
use more
iro in the world currently so camera i'm
gonna pivot back to you for a quick
rebuttal
um we think i think we get so caught up
in ira's quotes and his tea
and his sweetness that we forget that he
was once the dragon of the west
he was literally the crown prince of the
fire nation and he was supposed to be
king not
not ozai his crazy little brother oh
zuko's father
um his dream was to take over bossing
say and he
lost that battle and he didn't
he actually got into one wall but then
lost the second one
and that losing that battle lost him his
son and right after that
he lost his will to fight then he lost
his title
and then got demoted slower and slower
until he was then
basically ejected from the kingdom along
with zuko
so i honestly think had
iro not had that moment at that tree
losing his son he would have not
become who he is who he became to teach
zuko that there's a different way
there's a different lineage
you do not have to go this route because
i will learned it first
yeah the teaching of zuko that it's a
compelling argument that camera brings
up their mod so
i'm gonna give you the same amount of
time to win over maybe some hearts into
thumbs up for your team um yeah
this is not necessarily ira's story it
was important to acknowledge who ira is
and the place that he made in that but
that mistake cost him his
future his path so he invested in zuko
and he's realizing that zuko
never really had a good role model or
mentor and he adopted himself to kind of
be the father figure that zuko was never
going to get with ozai so
for me i think by imparting his wisdom
and knowledge
he is investing in his uh nephew to do
the good
that he wasn't allowed to do and that he
was denied um the whole premise of the
last airbender is that there's
four different elements and it's
creating harmony between all of them
and by the end zuko becomes the next
fire lord but it's only because he
learnt wisdom from many different places
and for the all of um or half of season
three he was teaming up with katara the
water bender
he was the fire bender he was learning
from aang the airbender and he was there
with toff the earthbender
that all of that information and being
able to put
his bs aside and listen and learn about
their perspectives
was he able to be the file the fire
nation the fire lord
that the whole not even the fire nation
but all of the world
needed from zuko so that couldn't have
happened without ira's
particular piece of knowledge about
drawing wisdom from different places
okay we're about to hear final arguments
from each side before we do that i want
to give a big shout in the chat to keith
cooper is just dropping some serious
knowledge
in the chat and dj kirkland might have
my favorite comment because dj says
i just finished rewatching the entire
series a few weeks ago
and now i'm ready to watch it again wow
uh
mod camera y'all are really getting more
eyeballs to netflix right now
to check out the 300 percent
fresh seasons on the tomato meter so
karema for your 10-second closing
argument let's drop a mic
basically everything for the fire nature
changed everything for the fire nation
excuse me changed
not when zuko was born or when aang was
freed from the ice
but when ira's son lieutenant died at
that tree
where he's singing that song
all right and maude this is this is an
ira story the the change that is
happening is all done through zuko
iro is investing in zuko by getting him
to see outside of his own privilege
by learning about other nations and
other people and becoming
balanced in himself so that particular
moment about
learning different perspectives and
seeking wisdom outside of it ira
delivered it so that zuko could be
the fire nation lord that everyone
deserved
okay uh two great arguments and i can
tell you how this is the closest
of the three rounds that we've had uh
chuck dragonblack collins in the chat
room says the real winner of this round
is
iro that is correct i would actually
agree with the [ __ ] there
and if there's a secondary winner it's
me for learning how to pronounce names
correctly but
we do have to give only one of our two
competitors the win and the point here
for round number three
and again closest margin yet it goes the
way of the thumbs up to mod so mod
reclaims
lead from round number one she once
again is up buy a point two
to one so here we go mod you're gonna
kick off
this round and karama it's it's do or
die you can force
a tiebreaker round five if mod wins this
round then mod you will be crowned the
champion
for avatar the last airbender binge
battle so
our fourth topic and possibly our last
round is
very simple what's the best season
finale you got three to pick from mod
which one are you taking
i'm going season one and that is because
the season one
that of all of those episodes was when
we were learning about the story who is
ang
what is going on here what are the
elements it was so explanatory
that with you know aang being the
titular character
the last airbender what does the avatar
mean what does it look like
there's been a lot of um issues
happening in the water tribes
they are sort of like the smaller more
nomadic kind of of all the tribes
and so that's what the fire nation is
attacking first um
aang has not learnt enough he is still
so green in this particular moment
he is unconscious for a lot of it
trapped in this meditative avatar state
um and this is when we discover what the
avatar powers can be
um and i i think that by ang becoming
and harnessing the ocean spirit
is the first oh damn moment that we had
where it was like this is what the show
is all about this is so
cool i am loving this the dichotomy
between
being so vulnerable and helpless with
zuko kind of like
in charge at that particular moment was
super important the fact that the water
tribe
where we know katara and soccer probably
the best out of the main groups like the
water tribes is where
our compassion is at so the fact that
that was under threat is a huge thing
um and also soccer guess some action
soccer was a bit of an earth character
for all of season one because not only
was he trying to be a leader but he was
the comic relief and he didn't really
know his strengths
but he had a lot of purpose in this
particular moment and so that was a
great growth for him
so i'm going to say with all of those
things with ang merging with the ocean
spirit
and taking out um the lord general at
that particular moment and just seeing
what a force this boy is
look at that badass thing oh so cool
that for me is the best season finale
because it made you locked
into the show and it also foreshadowed a
lot of what was to come
by seeing that the moon and the elements
above
actually held and manipulated and
enhanced or decreased
elemental powers and so i like the fact
that it was foreshadowing and re
leading us into a really exciting season
too it does a great job of a season one
finale it it
wraps up a lot of storylines but also
teases us to go check out next season so
uh mod you're going to like this nathan
swapp in the chat room says that maud is
dropping geek bombs here
but now it's caramel's turn to tell us
her
favorite season finale which one are you
taking
i'm taking season two because it's so
emotional
and now we do know all the characters we
do know
aang's powers we we we've been through
this emotional ending and now everything
seems so nice the whole season
lulls us into a false sense of security
and then just throws us off a cliff
basically zico has zuko rather has come
into his own he's living in the tea shop
with
uncle iro they're exiles they have a
whole other life now
he's turned a new leaf aang is back at
the um
airbender temple with gurupathik
learning
basically how to achieve the avatar
state saka gets to see his dad he's
going to go on a campaign katara
is in the earth kingdom as an advisor
and tough
figures out how to iron iron bend which
no one's ever done
and then and even appa escapes from
captivity and has no good very bad week
like everybody has something good
happened to them
and then all of a sudden of course here
comes azula and her girls and every
they invade the earth kingdom and just
at the end
when everybody is in that earth bending
earth kingdom cave
and we see aang come to save katara
because he leaves his airbending
training to see her not even knowing
he's ever going to become
part of the avatar state again he comes
to save her
brings her brother zuko is already there
and we're waiting for
him to fight his sister along with them
what does he do
he turns around and fights against them
not only does he fight against them
we are so in shock that he's done this
we almost miss azulla
shooting aang in the back and killing
him and yes i said it
he died he did it wasn't until qatar
used her water at the very very end of
the episode that he wakes up for a
moment
that you realize that at that moment
he's not dead but you don't know what's
going to happen
over the next season but all this stuff
that we've seen with zuko
all of this growth that we've seen with
the other characters it's like it's been
thrown out the window we've been
it was heart-wrenching i remember being
furious when zuko turned around and went
back with a sister
so and i don't think i'm alone in that
okay so that's a
it's a great point because yeah not all
endings or finales for that matter
necessarily have the happy ending that
you're rooting for with these characters
uh john giovanni heard karen's argument
and said
yes yes i get chills every time and lucy
chimed in saying caramel is correct it's
literally the empire strikes back
of avatar so it's it's neck and neck
right now again
if you're voting for karama and her
argument you're going to click that
heart if you're going mod garrett you're
going to click that thumbs up
so i'm mod gonna throw it right back to
you for your rebuttal what do you got
um yeah i do think that season two was a
lot but it was quite intense and i think
it was
slightly convoluted in the fact that
they were putting a lot in there pacing
wise
you kind of don't really catch on to the
fact that aang died
that was not done in like the most sort
of pivotal way whereas i feel like in
season one
the whole motion of getting to where he
is getting out of the abbest uh
getting into the avatar state becoming
infusing with the ocean spirit
this was such a badass moment where you
were able to
relish in what was happening like uh he
was fixing all the solutions he was
saving katara the girl that he loves
family like this entire tribe from the
fire nation
and also right at the end we are finally
introduced to
azulla and seeing her place in all of
this where she has completely replaced
zuko
and will be actually hunting him down so
it sets that up really nicely as well
because we know that azula is a huge
part of the show um i do think
the number one thing about the finale
though is that we are introduced to the
most
frightening creature that this entire
show had to offer
and that was co the face stealer
this is something where when ang goes
into that avatar state and when he's
exploring around a monkey turns around
without a face
and basically roku says to ang you are
about to talk to a spirit
where if you make any kind of emotion it
will steal your face
and aang is so new to all of this and
he's only just started this adventure
and to have that kind of pressure put on
him when everything around him is
slowly crumbling and he has to not show
any emotion to this
frightening creature that looks like
this giant spider
that was some of the best that the show
had to offer and i think that
you know season one is better because of
that
yeah someone no face comes at me i'm
probably gonna show a little bit of
emotion i will give you that uh
caramel it's all you for your rebuttal
why is season two
better of a finale than season one
i agree there was a lot of things that
people emotionally went through
with aang in that first first season
finale
and yes the face dealer is very creepy
i'm arachnophobic i agree with you
but we now in season two remember we're
beyond this he has survived that
and so all of the other things that
happened after this
meaning everybody is doing well and
they're moving towards their goal
at the end of that first season he
yes he masters water bending but he
doesn't have fire bending down yet
he really doesn't and that is why he's
so easily defeated
at the end of season two it is a
firebender
azula that takes him down and if he does
not learn firebending he literally
cannot fight
the firebender at the end of the entire
show so i still think
this is not as upsetting as zuko turning
his back on everyone this is not as
upsetting
as azula shooting him down and also
combustion bender hello much more
terrifying
uh this we have another great debate
here this is round number four so
uh robert jeffrey echoes my words he
says these are the type of debates i
love
and robert thank you for sharing the
stream really appreciate that
so now we move on to the final word
going to start with mod then go to
karama and once again get those last
votes and you're hitting that heart if
you side with karama you side with mod
you're hitting that thumbs up mod take
it away i think uh really you have to
look at what emotions are invoked
uh evoked from watching these finales
and for me
season two left me feeling quite upset
quite sad with how it all happened there
was a loss of hope at one stage
um i i felt really quite heavy about it
all but the end of season one
i felt liberated i felt empowered i felt
like i was so excited to continue this
show
and i felt like it was one of those
moments where maybe we are comparing the
fact that it's like a new hope because
the death star was blown up as far as
i'm concerned
and i was han being like yeah and that
for me
is why it is the better season finale
that's right then open mark term so he
gets it
then they built another death star and
it was hey look you all know returning
to jedi is my favorite star wars movie
but that's a different debate entirely
now karama it's your last word something
for season two
okay i'll use star wars as well aang is
basically
training with a guru so he can get to
his highest avatar state
and he has to leave his training and
risk his life
like luke had to leave that swamp and
his training with yoda
to go and save his friends and at the
end at the end of the day listen
two words aang died
that was the most terrifying moment i'm
sorry that's all i'm going to say on
that
well look i appreciate you all dumbing
it down to my star wars speak
for me because even though i'm not even
the jury here i'm just the judge i just
have the gavel and i'm just trying to
maintain some semblance of order
in my little courtroom here i appreciate
your catering to me
um and we did have some fans chime in
with the star wars
uh reference this is a good uh chuck
collins says season two is the turning
point it solidified the relationships of
all the characters
and gives you so much hope only to cut
off your hand like luke skywalker well i
do remember that
happy with the price drake's back so it
was between mod
and karama and sometimes we have a
tiebreaker round and that's only if
we're tied after round four which we are
caramel wins the point
and it is two to two it's in a deadlock
but not for long because we have that
tie breaker round if you've been
following us and watching previous binge
battles
this might be the most highly contested
one but i believe uh in one of our first
binge battles roxy stryer came back from
down 2-0 to lon harris to
ultimately win that so anything is
possible right now
we're deadlocked at two and we're gonna
go to our final debate topic which is
come on this is any show so you say
what's the best episode what
is the best episode of avatar the last
airbender just to make it fair with a
little bit of randomness
um karama because you're currently
broadcasting from further away
i'm going to give you the courtesy of
being the away team so i'm thinking of a
number between one and two which number
am i thinking of
hmm two that is
what i am thinking so caramel would you
like to go first
in the tiebreaker round or would you
like to defer to mod
um i'll go first it's fine camera's
ready to go so without further ado
what's the best episode of avatar the
last airbender
i personally think the best episode and
avatar the last airbender is the blue
spirit episode
uh season one episode 13. um
for several reasons one we haven't
talked about this much at all we've
talked about a lot of characters
the animation of this show and
specifically
in this episode when basically zuko you
don't know it at the time is donning the
mask and becoming the blue spirit to go
break out aang that animation is is
amazing so
j m animation studio in korea shout out
to them
they've also done green lantern there's
also done dante inferno if you want to
like
for some geek stuff there but this
episode is not just
amazingly animated but you literally see
for the first time
zuko and ang working together we don't
know
he doesn't know who's under that mask he
knows he's we know that zuko is going up
against the fire lord who is trying to
kill him but he also wants to get his
honor back
so you never know throughout the episode
is he gonna
actually take aang is he gonna kill him
he's gonna hurt him or is he gonna set
him free
in the end he actually
needs aang to save him which is not what
we're expecting
so this is one of those again it's a
turning point also
for zuko it is i i would say a
foreshadowing
for the series finale that we were just
talking about but it really
is this episode really gives us an idea
of the two characters how they're
battling each other but how they're
actually two sides of the same coin
so for me it's blue spirit episode one
season 13.
okay so uh i got good news karen i know
you have at least two votes for you
because i was looking at the chat room
and colin and jimmy both lit up
when he said blue spirits so you got at
least two hearts coming your way
everybody else can click the heart to
vote for caramel or you can click the
thumbs up to vote for mod
and her favorite episode which is
season three chapter five the beach
now we have had two over two seasons
full of learning about katara
introducing toff
knowing about saka and how he is a
crucial part of the team
and also understanding aang's journey
what we never really got a lot of uh
time with
is azula mae tai li and
zuko with the with those particular
friends and his sister
we are seeing for the first time teenage
relationships
and i call this the therapy episode
they are all talking about their
feelings they are pinpointing
why behavior is occurring you are like
this because of how you were raised
the reason why you want attention so
much is because you never had any and
you were one of seven kids
these really healthy discussions
normalized
talking about why you behave in a
particular way
expressing and pinpointing the exact uh
reason behind it
and then growing from it this was so
crucial for children and adolescents and
adults to watch
and the fact that they made it the best
episode because it's teenage hornbag
content
i was there hanging on to every single
word it was because they were doing
basically their spring break
where all the fire nation kids or
teenagers got together
uh when they were having a bit of a
party and a holiday and they were at a
house party
and then they realized that they didn't
fit in and so they went to the beach and
they had these in-depth discussions
uh you see the fact that men fawn over
ty lee
and she's like the way that she's
responding and reacting to it is super
innocent but then all of a sudden it's
really annoying azula
and she's understanding that no one's
really giving her attention and why that
is so she tries to change herself so
that guys like her
but she hasn't got that capability
because she's an absolutely evil pos
um and then you're also understanding my
and a um
and zuko's relationship we'd never
really seen how or why it happened
the reason why they got together was
because there was a little bit of a oh
yeah you're gonna be cool to see
zuko again because the last time wink
wink but now we're actually seeing them
as a couple and why they work well
together
this for me was so emotionally and
behaviorally advanced
and so important to i feel the society
and the viewers
and there's snoochie all right it's blue
spirit versus
the beach fun fact about the beach is
that the voice actor who plays
zula that's actually their favorite
episode uh i'm not that smart i just
stole that fact from colin hanrahan in
the chat so thank you colin for making
me look like i know what i'm doing uh
caramel we're gonna go back to you for
your 30-second rebuttal mod made a great
argument about the beach
you made a great argument about blue
spirits so add on to it
okay i'm sorry horn bag 1987 call they
want their phrase back
so listen the beach episode
it's fun but in anime we call that a
filler episode
it's not giving us the action in a lot
of the
major storylines and the major major
story arcs that we want
commander zao has basically had it out
for zuko
this entire time for basically most of
um season one even the fire learned ozai
doesn't know that he's tried to kill his
kid
so he's literally out to get him
and zuko is out to rescue aang
not just because he wants to save aang's
life because he wants to basically
give a finger basically to zhao he
literally has
uses his batman like strength he goes
like into full
this isn't even his final form but we
see the fact that he
is actually not just a firebander but
he's good with his hands
so that is what's so amazing we get to
see so much action
and there's so much that happens at the
end of this episode
when aang saves his life put zuko's
asleep in the woods
with him and aang is waiting for him to
wake up
he wants to see are you still my friend
and zuko shoots a fire blast at him
and that's how he knows the chase is
going to continue so i'm sorry blue
spirit i think is still a better episode
all right it it took five rounds but it
might have just got personal mod because
camera coming in with the f word filler
how do you regret it um i actually kind
of want to use her previous argument
against her
and that is season two was better than
season one apparently because we were
more invested in the characters
i think by the time we're in this
episode in season three we are far more
invested because we
know these characters and this episode
was able to fill in the parts of their
character that we didn't know yet so it
completely fleshed them out
as a whole this episode also brought us
into the introduction of combustion man
which was not a filler moment at all it
was something that affected
a lot of episodes after that and the
fact that it was zuko that sent him as
well
like what that's not a good thing and
combustion man is so
so dangerous and destructible and that
power is something that we hadn't seen
before because a little eye opens up in
the middle of his head
so that juxtaposition between aang and
his crew trying to relax in a hot spring
and then coming across an enemy
that can blow up things with a
combustion of energy at them
and then seeing the bad guys our little
foursome that are having their spring
break moment
and talking about their feelings was
such a lovely contradiction
and it was really showing things that we
hadn't seen yet in this
show that was quite necessary by the
time we got to episode three
i loved learning about tylee's history i
loved learning more about mai and how
she grew up
and i think it is so important to
reflect um
you know childhood trauma can surf this
in particular ways
but when you are becoming an adult you
realize more that's happening out there
and then it can become a choice and i
think
this pivotal moment is why zuko cannot
ever associate necessarily with his
sister
and sees a bigger picture for him
personally
and i think you know especially in anime
it can be a lot about you know
explosions and the fights and the battle
sequences
this was so much deeper and enriching in
an emotional way
i the the beach knees and trunks it's
you also have that at the beach so
that's a great counter argument
uh to caramel's postulation so we are
going to go back to
karama and then to mod for their final
argument it all comes down to this
i think i speak for both competitors
when i say we could go 15
20 rounds but we are under some time
constraints so unfortunately this is the
last round
the tie breaker round hit that heart if
you're siding with caramel you want her
to win the binge battle
hit that thumbs up if you want mod to
take the whole thing so karama
it's your last argument in today's
matchup have
at it uh you're absolutely right mod
about
the trauma yes all of the trauma in
zuko's life is the whole reason
why he's wearing the blue spirit mask
the mask
from his mother the mask that is the
only representation he actually has
left of her and it's the first inkling
that we have that zuko may be more
redeemable
and aang may go out on a limb
and fight for him remember where this is
this this episode is placed
so yeah i see we're flip-flopping a
little bit but i'm definitely gonna say
that
this in terms of pivotal moments that
you remember when you think
back on all of all of avatar when you go
back and watch all of them
this episode the blue spirit episode is
one that you remember i don't think most
people remember what happened at the
beach
besides combustion man so i'm i'm
sticking with blue spirit sticking with
blue spirit
it's all you mod when i look back i
think that that episode uh in season
three is such a pivotal moment because
we're really understanding the core of
all of these characters and identifying
who they are
as a person for the first time we have
seen azula be such an indestructible
sociopathic uh antagonist here
but in the beach episode we saw her
vulnerabilities we saw that she had a
particular weakness and that she didn't
feel good enough
and that ended up becoming her demise so
i think that
a really great part of storytelling is
not having a good guy and a bad guy for
the sake of it
it's understanding that they truly think
that what they are doing is good
um but why it might not necessarily be
bad and i think the fact that this is a
show that children to adults watch
the fact that they are normalizing
discussions about behavior
that they are recognizing trauma that
they are normalizing
the the way to talk to friends and
what's acceptable and what's not
and how to grow as a person to be better
is for me the most fundamental element
and they play beach volleyball
i love every every one of mods arguments
in this round
ends with just something fun you get to
do at a beach so it really is an
appropriately named episode
if nothing else this is maybe been the
best argument
of them all and why not if we saved it
for the tiebreaker round
if you know me at all you know i love
competition i love competing i love
hosting events like this
but man is this where the job gets tough
because i do have to announce there can
be only one
there can be only one highlander you
voted with your hearts for caramel you
voted with your thumbs up
vermont and even though it's like in
love i think we both love each other
equally
but your winner today of the last
airbender
binge battle fighting out of brooklyn
new york
it is the blurred girl caramel horn oh
my god
w congratulations i totally didn't think
i got so
fun whoa
how's it feel thank you no honestly it's
that's what we were sort of saying in
the breaks that
there's so much of the stuff that we
just discussed and what you saw going on
with the fans
in the chat this is why avatar the last
airbender the animated series
is such a fan favorite that like
everything that we were just talking
about you you're not gonna go anywhere
to any convention to any
to any panel to any group to any social
media and
not bring up hey what do you think about
avatar the last airbender and have
discussions like this i know you've had
them on so but thank you
i will talk about this show forever and
like just being able to express it and
fight for good components of the same
show
it is totally worthy if it's 100 over
three seasons if it's been more than a
year that you've watched it watch it
again
it's like been the highlight of my
lockdown it's such a
good show it is laugh out loud funny it
has
such powerful moments it's yeah it's
just
so good and i'm just i am i am so
thankful for our tech team we're not
done yet by the way we got a couple
streaming pics to get to so stick with
us for
uh just a little bit more on facebook
and youtube but our tech team brought us
together to have a cool argument about
fun nerdy stuff
on a weekend when i'm pretty sure the
three of us would all be
traveling to san diego to go to
comic-con and that's not happening this
year but we got to have one of those
great
late night we'd do one more round of the
hotel bar debates before people go to
our rooms and it was just such a
pleasure to hang out with you all today
karema you are a winner so i'll start
with you do you have a current streaming
pick that you're
looking at that you think maybe a lot of
our fans would enjoy
um if you haven't caught the old guard
yet
i think you should definitely check it
out um it was
it's really it's based on a comic book
you don't have to have read the comics
but they are good based on the greg
rucker series um
and they're actually coming to win end
that comic
very very soon they're talking about
rebooting it so the old guard starring
charlize
really good on netflix and it for my
anime fans
fire force the second season of fire
force is out one of my new favorite
characters
oguru montgomery uh is there and that's
over on funimation
so those are my two picks all right ma
i've got to turn it over to you
uh i know it's it's tough to take an l
but you adjudicated yourself very well
in your fandom and your love for
avatar the last airbender um what are
some other good streaming pics that our
fans can check out
i want to echo the sentiments about old
guard uh support female directors and
gina prince spike who did such an
amazing job with this film
and my suggestions kind of also showcase
why i love old guard
i love seeing female protagonists that
are so amazing at what they do and they
challenge stereotypes so mine
and this is what i have been binging
these lockdowns um buffy the vampire
slayer which i like to do at least every
four years because it's an amazing
series
it was revolutionary for its time um and
also
oh yeah the chemistry the everything i
love that show
um but then also alias which is jj
abrams um
and this is a series you know a cia
operative sydney bristow played by
uh judge jennifer ghana my gosh
like blank i'm like what's her name
again it's always going to be bristow to
me
um she basically thinks that she's been
in the cia the whole time but has been
fighting on
the wrong side of um you know good and
evil
and seeing that relationship unfold with
her cia operative when she finally comes
to the truth the relationship with her
father
the fact that she is so strong
physically but also here and she's so
good at her job
that to me is what is inspiring and i
love that uh some more great work out
there uh by a
very promising young female director
check out relic
not the relic this relic check it out it
builds
all three acts and you get to a
crescendo and boy you like horror movies
it's a slow burn but man does it pay off
at the end so check out relic and then
of course because i'm me
the last dance go watch it again like
i'm doing
because it's mj and it's always time for
mj so
with that we're about to say goodbye but
karema i had such a good time hosting
this event with you
where can all the kids out there check
out the stuff that you're working on i
know you're on twitch every tuesday is
that right
yeah basically i have a new show called
the blur girl live where i interview all
kinds of creators that are
in the geek space well not their
directors or writers or actors or things
like that
and uh my uh guest
on oh wait no my guess changed so you'll
have to go to the blurgirl.com
to see who the next guest is i'm
actually the blurred girl everywhere
t-h-e-b-e-r-d
i get mail on twitter but you can always
find me on instagram
as well and yeah i have i also have a
podcast and i do about 100 other things
but if you follow me on twitter you'll
be able to basically figure out what i'm
doing
that's right and luckily we're all
allowed back into twitter now after
yesterday so
that and once again if you want to
follow uh camera it's the word girl
spelled with the u
not with the i-g-u-r-l and mod uh we
know about you creating the
incredible endeavor that is geekbomb and
you're hosting
uh fresh daily on quibby that's five
days a week that's every weekday
uh where else can the kids find you yeah
the good thing about fresh daily is that
it's a streaming recommendation show so
if you're sitting there going what is
good and what can i watch we got you
covered there
um geekbomb just celebrated it's it's
the eighth birthday
and i would mean a lot to you press the
subscribe button on the youtube channel
because i've got a new show called power
up
and that's all about discussing what
i've been playing watching and reading
throughout the week i do it with trisha
hershberger who's an another amazing
woman in the geek space
and we have guests every other week for
that this week will be troy baker which
is so exciting because he's the voice of
joel from the last of us
um but then we also do a new thing
called power down but it's a patreon
exclusive
but i have very lately been using it
therapeutically
to get very deep and personal and
vulnerable which is a new thing for me
so if you want to be involved with that
just subscribe to geekbombs patreon
where you will also get the after show
for the weekly book club that i do with
nerdist so we are actually covering a
star wars book
this month claudia gray's bloodline
which i'm stoked about
i actually read that that's one of the
very few but i'm not great at reading
but i did actually read
claudia gray's great so um good lust out
horn
is our winner today mod i do have
something you know this is my therapy
smart i just wanted to remind you that i
still have the game boy
that i brought to chili's like actually
that reminds me i've just been announced
as the social uh the
community correspondent for the new
tetris show
that i'm hosting where they get you to
play a new game every single
night and you can win money and be
ranked against everyone in the world
so i need you to sign up for that
because you do brilliant things with
tetris
all right molly what do you think should
i sign up for okay well she's still
taking a nap but
oh i forgot something i just completely
forgot i'm hosting i'm hosting one of
the panels at san diego comic-con
i was in the humanoids panel uh for the
whole
humanoids team mark wade and the entire
team of all their stuff coming up
my assistant was like what are you doing
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
was that your sister or was that houdini
running in with the last minute
that would be amazing if houdini had
that gift oh my god
so yes actually my next guest on the
blur girl live is matthew cherry and i'm
also going to be hosting
um a san diego comic-con panel and i
think we're all going to be doing
comic-con at home next week right with
our drinks
virtual stuff one way or another and
thank you all for gracing us
with your presents here today thanks to
our incredible rotten tomatoes tech team
i'm looking at alex
ryan kelly zoe uh lucy everybody behind
the scenes helping us out here ed making
things go so
thanks to our entire staff rotten
tomatoes i am mark ellis for
caramel horn and maud garrett and the
pets we'll see y'all next time on binge
battle
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
you